Así es Y pues para digamos celebrar este
aniversario Manuel respondió a las
preguntas de al menos once lectores del
diario lo París ya y el resultado de
toda esta entrevista Pues fue publicado
en la noche de este domingo allí el
presidente pues se hace otra especie de
mea culpa diciendo que efectivamente lo
hubiera tenido debido apersonarse más de
esta reforma pensional para que no fuera
digamos Eh pues recibida de la manera
que que lo fue de estar un poco más
presente y él de alguna manera dice
bueno Esto va a cambiar Yo estoy de
regreso sobre un poco digamos el debate
público por eso la semana pasada estuvo
visitando varias regiones del país allí
fue recibido con cacerolazos fue
abucheado Se espera también a finales de
esta semana que haga otro desplazamiento
a otras ciudades de el país pero también
aparte de eso pues se aprovechó para dar
a conocer Cuáles son los ejes de estos
próximos cuatro años que le quedan en el
Eliseo Por una parte dijo que la
situación económica del país después en
cuanto a la inflación las cosas no van a
mejorar al menos de aquí a finales de
septiembre especialmente en el precio de
los alimentos también habló de la ley
inmigración Hace unos días en su
alocución él había dicho que era un
texto de ley que quizás iba a dividirse
en varios textos de ley sin embargo en
esta última entrevista él dice que será
uno solo en el que se quiere ser mucho
más estricto con la integración de los
extranjeros en el país y sobre todo que
se haga con más celeridad la expulsión
de personas que ya no debe no deben
estar en territorio francés también
aprovechó para pues hablar de los
problemas que hay en los servicios de
urgencias en los hospitales del país
diciendo pues que tiene un proyecto para
eso que sabe que hay una falta de mano
de obra y sobre todo pues que espera
también poner sanciones a aquellos
pacientes que incumplen citas médicas y
ya por último digamos que también pues
se responde a a lo que todo este
malestar político y social que se ha
generado o con la reforma pensional pues
puede tener como consecuencias en el
futuro y por eso hablaba que en caso de
no responder a los desafíos de el país
pues es muy probable que la extrema
derecha encabezada por Martín López
llega al poder en 2027